製作人余承
把它劈開
把它扣掉
加入明君
加UP
哇你看
團隊的實力就UP了
均線怎麼走就可以余承
而且是百分之百喔
對
這叫扣底值
明天這個季線
它會往A走
繼續往上走
對
看得到的利多都不是利多
投馬會走在股價前面
當你看到利多的時候
當然就是主力在到貨了
喊整
主力又吸貨
快要發動了我買
主力買股價還沒漲
最漂亮
這一段啊
主力吃嘛
吃一隻肉
吃飽後
你這樣就漲了
月見相關加上主力在大賣
那幾乎就是完蛋
閃霧人手一張
風吹炒動了
大家都很害怕
所以你看到高點出現20天內
對
讓你跑的喔
小哥
第二集了我還是有點不敢相處
為什麼
因為以前我在網路上
就非常景仰你
就是一個一天到晚秀對賞單
我就覺得啊 這人很臭屁耶
很臭屁喔 對
這是負責任的表現嘛
負責任的表現
至少讓網友知道我還在交易啊
對 但是後來你願意來上理財達人秀
就整個開心
對 就覺得哇 我們整體的有沒有
彭幣聲輝
真的啊
達人秀的軍線穩定上揚
真的嗎 就是你的加入
真的喔 可是我覺得
跟某一個人合作感覺怪怪的
什麼
對啊 跟你合作我覺得很開心啊
可是你們
其中我工作人員
每次問我問題
傳訊給他都已讀不回
蛤?這麼怠慢啊
對啊
他在現場嗎?
好像有欸
然後他的題目又設定得很爛
然後常常被我罵
都要花我好多時間喔
小哥的專業常常被他弄扭曲
怎麼會幫我換個顏值比較高的啊
指出來是哪一個
你有顏值的看來就我嘛
對 你有顏值
然後再來就小哥嘛
對對對
我們有個工作人員就覺得他怪怪的
製作人余誠
對
混水摸椅的學生
看能不能把它踢開
把它扣掉
對 把它扣掉
好 為什麼小哥會這樣說呢
我們先來做個開場
我們今天是
歌有仇必報的第二集
第二集呢
小哥為什麼一開場
就那麼辛辣的批判了我們的製作人余誠
因為今天要教大家的東西
非常的重要喔 一定要記起來喔
大家一定都會想說
常常會看均線對不對
均線上彎就是在微笑對不對
可是如果均線下彎呢
那代表什麼
小哥告訴你
那代表出現了
混水摸魚的壞學生
所以今天這堂課很重要的原因是
小哥要來帶你預測
預測接下來的均線
到底會上揚還是下彎
欸 百分之百準耶 小哥
對 沒錯
預測均線百分之百準
對
預測明天漲跌就不是百分之百準了
還有不行 均線準
漲跌多半也準起來了對不對
對 他的勝率會提高
那怎麼提高勝率
剛剛講了我們已經先把我們的壞學生
對 我們叫他
混水摸魚的學生踢開
對 我們來看一下
這三張的顏值
平均
還有團隊的實力
是不是 就up了
up加入民軍對不對
你看這個
小哥 不行啦
為什麼加入一個跟我比的女生
這兩個都是女神等級的
那你要選哪一個
我要選哪一個 當然是選你啊
是不是 眼睛看我嘛
對不對
小哥果然很上到
好 其實小哥舉這些例子就是告訴我們
其實可以預測
因為我們把壞的踢出去
均線可以預測
對 然後把美女加進來
沒錯 那均線就會上揚
好 那怎麼樣百分之百預測
今天看到製作人給我這張板
我嚇一跳
嚇一跳
你看他上面寫說
小哥可以百分之百預測線怎麼走
線怎麼走
那不是挖坑給我跳嗎
可是我常聽到一句話
大家都講說台股的趨勢是
小哥畫線給台股走
沒有
這句話太浮誇了
因為預測線怎麼走
這個太難了
為什麼
因為今天錄影時間1月14號
我想預測錯了
你們馬上就看得到
因為你要預測未來走是
有困難 但是
我剛剛麻煩幫我改一下
預測均線怎麼走
均線怎麼走就可以預測
而且是百分之百喔
對 我們講季線還可以啦
五日線可能會比較困難一點
因為五日線跟明天的走勢會有很大關係
那季線就沒有問題
季線的成員比較多
對 季線成員比較多
我們看一下60天的
你看這邊有個小箭頭
這叫扣底值
扣底值太難了啦
沒關係 我們先跟各位講
待會會詳細解釋
扣底值剛好在比較低的地方
所以現在在比較高的地方
所以明天這個季線
它會往A走
繼續往上走
明天會往A走
你去翻1月15號的K線
你就會看到它會往A走
明天的線我都幫你畫好了
今天季線還是往A走
這個等到露營播出的時候
各位看就知道了
其實股價怎麼走
或者股價的線怎麼走
我們沒有要那麼貪心啦
可是因為均線我們都知道
均線如果上彎
或者說股價有沒有站上什麼均線
這對我們來說很重要
如果我們能預測還是很有用啊
對 沒錯
這個會讓你的勝率提高
可是剛剛小哥講一個扣底值
我覺得這就太難了
我覺得就失去我們理財達安秀的精神
我們要簡單
入門的觀眾全部都聽得懂
什麼是扣底值
小哥考驗你囉
我是老師
老師就是要把不會的交到會
好
我們現在交均線
那什麼叫均線
我們先講一個最簡單的
五日均線
那五日均線
我們就要把這五天的價格平均
對
好 趙華先考你
是
這五天的價格平均是多少
用心算的
不是
沒有比
用心算
你不是要交扣底
變成數學 沒關係
我們先考一下天價多少
我加一下
7加2 9加12 12加法
20然後除以5天
趙華你以前已經是學霸對不對
沒有啦 還好啦
因為我
數字感好一點而已
這個問過很多人
他都是怎麼加呢
107加102加103
他這樣加的很累
對啊 後面不就各位數加起來
大腦的loading會很重
那事實上這題很簡單
因為它一定是100零幾
這平均不可能超過110
也不可能低於100
對
所以我們只要把後面
7加2加3加5加3
加起來20
所以答案是多少
好 我們來看答案
好 就是4
5日舉一下104
難得被學堂考
我剛剛超緊張的
果然是學霸
好 那我再問一個問題
下個交易日要是多少
2月下一個交易日可能是2月8號
好
2月8號呢
這個要價格收盤價是多少
5日均線
5日均線就說
2月2號 3號 4號 5號 8號
對
這加起來
那條線
這條線呢才會上揚
要多少
好
這一題是副選題
副選題
對要考副選
我懂剛剛小哥有教我
均線的概念
就是要把坏學生踢出去
好學生加進來它才會漲
所以只要有好學生
應該就會漲了吧
所以比平均值大的
105 108 複選嘛
對
這兩個加進去
這兩個都會漲
所以你的答案是105 108
對啊
好 正確答案是
只有108
那你還跟我說什麼複選
那故意的 故意的
複選題裡面
你答一個答案它也是複選
小哥很尖詐
我現在提高警覺
因為假如跟你說單選
每個人都會選單選選最高的就對了
選最高就漂亮的啊
所以故意跟你講複選
但事實上他答案還是一個而已
答案還是108
那為什麼
明明105就比均價來得高啊
對啊
那為什麼105加進來之後
沒有拉上去
平均沒有上升
你可以加看看啊
2加3加5
10嘛
10加3加5
只有18而已啊
所以平均還是下降了啊
因為這邊有一個好學生
他不見了
對 有個好學生 對
所以這個值叫做扣底值
我們可以這樣想
這2月1號107
就是有個學生他考107分
他2月1號那一天
這個只要
因為我們班上位置不夠大
一天只能容納5個我們淘汰率比較高所以2月1號那一天107這個學生必須要轉走那進來2月就下一個交易日那個
假如他的分數沒有超過107的話
對
本班的平均就會怎麼樣
下降
懂了
本班平均下降
5日均線就會下降
懂了
這樣懂了
完全懂了
所以下個交易日
一定要108均線才會上揚
扣底子就是這個概念
好 但是好 我現在懂了
可是我經歷過千辛萬苦
我會算了
請問這對我操作有什麼幫助
很有幫助
來 我們馬上找一個案例
我現在只是很開心
余城轉走而已 沒別的
我很開心有個美女轉進來
我來看一下
看這個1909榮城
好 問一下趙婉
是
來 你看一下這個月線長這樣
對
今天出現一根紅K
好
红K我们上礼拜有交
出现红K我们该怎么办
好
这档你要不要买
上一集才刚交
我告诉你
这个线它还是微微下弯
它还没有站上月线
照道理来说我应该不要买
但是小哥上次教我们红K
他留一个下影线
就等于他收盘的时候还被拉上去
有买器
有阻力
可能下一根就会站上月线了
我提早布局我买
提早布局你买
对
好
那這個比較可惜的是喔
它不是盤整突破大紅K
對 它不是什麼光頭
因為上面還有重重脈壓嘛
那你假如在這邊買呢
會發生什麼事情呢
發生什麼事
發生什麼事情 我們來看一下
我又被光了
會發生這個事情
什麼事
你買在這一根
不對啊 我應該是這根吧
我買在這根
對 因為你這一根呢
你之前的20天喔
這條線叫月線嘛
對
所以扣底值呢
就是20天前
對
20天前都是好學生啊
月線
好 往前推20天
在這一區
都好學生
都是帥哥美女
對
這成績都很好
股價都很高
是
假如進來一個股價沒有突破它的話
這個想當然很難突破
就來個普男
對
我說普妹會被罵普男
假如是一個普通的
對
股價沒有很高的話
那這條線還是會往下
對
月線往下
大家壓力都很大
對
因為有太多書跟我們講
月線往下不要買
對 所以這些書講的是真的
對 因為股市是
綜合大家心理
造成的價格
那看到月線往下
不要買不要買
我們等月線往上再買就好了
所以我們再問你下一個問題
好
剛剛這個你答錯了
答錯會怎麼樣
假如你買錯了
跌下來你會很掙扎
要不要停損
打電話給小哥
然後小哥就會說
趕快熱白殺出
打電話給古魚
古魚說唇骨
就崩潰了
我覺得唇骨滿好的
唇骨只有唇
抱著沒有賣
所以都不會
心情都不會受創
我們再來看這個
那假如再出現這根紅K
有點頭髮的紅K
我覺得我上了你的K棒
反而整個人有點變得混淆了
變得混淆了
好 但是它站上月線了
對 站上月線
而且它大放量
而且這根紅K很長
很長
代表它的就是漲很多
所以買氣足
買氣夠足
對
所以我再買
再買
事實上是根本沒有賣就在家
在家
我們來看一下
扣底值這時候已經到這個位置了
對
所以在一根K棒進來
這個就會被怎麼樣
淘汰
被淘汰
這個被淘汰
之後它的扣底值就越來越低囉
扣底值低
那代表之後呢
轉走的同學都是怎麼樣
比較差的
成績比較差的
對
成績比較差的轉走
那只要股價在這裡混
月線就會怎麼樣
就會往上漲
對 月線就會往上漲
轉來一個無宜農了
很可惜他沒有選上
沒關係 我留著欣賞
好的
好
看一下
大家現在應該很了解了
了解一下
原來你是農富
是是是
好 我来看一下这里
你呢 就买在这一根
对
那之后月线呢 就往上走
对 股价站上月线
终于买对了
对 那每个人看到
哇 股价站上月线
往上一回挡
哎呀 回挡
葛兰币八大法则买点啊
葛兰币八大法则都来了
我们还没讲过
葛兰币八大法则
我们等小哥以后再来讲
所以呢
只要一回挡都是个好买点
你看 一回挡呢 就一根红K
一回答红K
大家买股信心十足
越爆越涨
这叫月线上升
有助涨的力道
这样我懂了
我只要懂得去看扣底值就好了
我就看月线的话往前数20天
好学生转进来我就买
如果学生转出去我就卖
所以我们就把工作给迟了
就好做股票就好了
就这么一套方法
小哥好佛心
股票没那么简单
我们教这个方法
只是讓你的勝率提高了大概10%
10%
之後呢
我們再教很多種方法
會讓你勝率越來越高
不行 10%不夠
10%不夠
因為我們現在勝率就趨近於0而已
好 沒關係
交給我
所以10%不夠
所以是不是我除了看這個
小哥應該還會有教我們
因為我們是哥有仇必報
有仇必報
我們要把籌碼加進來
對 我們把籌碼加進來
勝率就立刻變成90%
勝率就提高非常多了
非常多
小哥不敢把話說那麼滿
90%
應該有啦
應該有
不能說百分之百
請Quart 98在字幕上放大90%的勝率
講百分之百呢
就是兩個
一個是神
一個是神棍
所以我們不能講百分之百
沒關係百分之90
百分之90就很強了
小哥
比如說這個是我們最喜歡的一個形態
怎麼說呢
那這種形態呢
它是股價在高漲
對
那各位我們看一下
這個前高在86.8
在這根
只要到这个前高
没有再创新高的话
那按照我们刚刚讲的
月线扣底概念
往后数20天
它就要下弯了
这个月线就很容易下弯
所以第20天后
股价角没过前高
月线就容易下弯
月线容易下弯
为什么要等月线下弯
因为这档标的
它主力已经在高档做什么事情了
大
賣超
小哥這下面有一個主力買賣超
主力賣當然就慘了啊
主力賣就慘了
我們很相信主力的耶
他為什麼還沒點你知道嗎
為什麼
因為在這個地方利多一堆
利多一堆
這麼奇怪
就是主力一直賣
他利多一直放
那不就是俗稱的到貨嗎
對 沒錯
很多股票都長這樣
在高檔主力放利多
他拼命到
可是你在這時候進場
你在这时候进场你去空它
就很容易被嘎
但是你只要等到怎么样
等到高点出现后的20天
它的月线下弯
它就很难嘎你了
但是小哥
主力买卖超
这不是那么容易拿到
你是看什么
你要解释一下
什么叫主力买卖超
主力买超
有人在买有人在卖
对不对
我解释一下
好
我们现在看这个分点
这个主力买超定义是这样子
全台前15大分点的买超
减去全台前15大分点的卖超
它就会等于主力买超
但是这个等一下你会告诉我哪里查
哪里查 对
因为不然我哪有办法去捞这个分点
那这个哪边查
这个现在市面上一堆软体都有了
我们最后再来讲
很多看盘的软体免费的也都有
好 没问题
我现在先举一个筹码K的
好
这是筹码K软体
筹码K线软体
我们现在看这个主力
我们没有卖软体
還是先講
希望籌碼k線願意贊助我們一下
斗內一下
斗內 斗內 籌碼k線賺很大
我們來看主力聯買的威力
這個是董監改選
這在三年前很有名的一檔股票
叫榮鋼
我在這裡主力都大買
對啊 一路大買
我們看這邊主力大買的時候
在這段其實還沒大漲
所以我在這邊我也跟著買很多
就是這一小段你就上車了
我就上車了
因為我看到主力買超
而且我去看一下他的分點
我懂了 這段是主力買 這段小哥買
我跟著主力一起買
主力帶著我往北走 很開心
主力住哪邊 這個也蠻重要的
有分點資料 要看一下主力住在哪裡 你看買方前15名的第一名低金嘉義第二名他已經併了分點了我記得叫大眾 輕盈
第三名叫元大府城
第四名元大金華 兆豐嘉義 凱基北門
你有沒有覺得好像都住在
某些地方 都住在南部
都住在嘉義跟台南
嘉義跟台南分點
他們最喜歡玩董金改選
有這個癖好就對了
我怎麼只記得嘉義是小虎隊
就是短線客
那就是富邦嘉義
富邦嘉義他沒有出現在這邊
這幾個分點是喜歡玩董監改選
他們都波段買進
所以等於是有董監改選的題材
又看到這些分點在買
對小哥來說就是
就是上車的訊號
這班車要開到3月中
對啊 趕快上車
所以那時候我們就有上車
跟到3月中
主力聯買很好
所以這有標的賺滿多的
這個聽起來很簡單
主力連邁本來就很好啊
對 沒錯
但是應該就是
小哥等一下應該會考我男的
我們先繼續看小哥要說什麼
你怎麼知道
我現在害怕這個李化老師
我們就是要讓學員在考試中成長
小哥外貌忠厚
其實內心兇險
沒有 其實內心還是很老實的
好 我們來看
主力連邁的下場
這個是最近的一檔股票
4157太景KY
太景KY在這個點
在這個點還有一個超大的利多
待會兒我們給各位看利多
大利多的時候
大利多讓它開高
開高走低
各位你記得
你看了新聞之後
一早衝進去
結果今天收黑K
你就要很小心
新聞大利多卻收黑K
收黑K它就是一個出貨的新聞
出貨新聞
那我們假如晚上再看這個籌碼
通常是這樣
你假如今天黑K的話
今天大概就是主力賣潮
那看籌碼確認主力賣潮
那賣的分點
你看照封南京
在這裡拼命賣啊
哇
你看那一天可以賣到2000張
殺紅眼的賣
很誇張
那這個阻力呢
趁著利多
我們來看這個利多
好
11月29號
就是那個跳空開高那一天
好
哇 你看這個台灣新藥研發公司
太景KY啊
那旗下的抗生素
哇 你看這個
大陸中國醫保
看到中國醫保
哇塞
這個錢一定很多啊
哇 你又占13億
口白是95市場
市場規模有10億人
10億人民幣
看到這個利馬進去利馬套牢
為什麼
他這個不是要現賺4、50億台幣了嗎
這種利多我都不敢相信
你看得到的利多都不是利多
人家幹嘛告訴你對不對
籌碼會走在股價前面
當你看到利多的時候
那就是主意在到貨了
所以籌碼還是最準的
籌碼是最準的
對
我們再來看
這金彩科
在這段過程中
我們看到這段過程中主力連賣
是
股家媒體喔
主力連賣
對
那誰賣呢
趙豐永和在這邊連賣
對
他是誰喔
其實我也知道他是誰
他是誰
從這邊看得到
好
在下一頁就看得到
趙豐永和看得到是誰
好
看得到
是誰
好
這個利多劍報
對
主力申報轉讓
喔
所以趙豐永和就是那位申報轉讓的主力
對
沒錯
申報轉讓的主力
好
而且這主力趁什麼時候申報轉讓
我們看一下
AOI设备厂精彩科前4月
EPS 2.19元
基本面好
很多人都会算
前4月2.19元
乘以三
12个月多少乘以三
股票不是那么简单
至少赚6块
不是用这样乘的好吗
刚同事有算了
前三季有公布EPS
还是两块多
你看主力早就知道了
主力早就知道后面营收变差
在那个时候
你看到營收YY都是100%以上
所以你的意思是
古魚教我們看營收和EPS是不準的
好公司OK
我也沒說金采克是爛公司
我只是說主力到貨的公司你要很小心
重點是看到籌碼
他配小哥看籌碼
剛才講說趙鋒永和
趙鋒永和是誰呢
來 趙鋒永和是誰
是誰 抓到了
主力抓到了
油田上月完成處分5300張
看到没有
大股东
大股东真狠
对 大股东到货
对
他趁着利多到货
一堆董事还申报转让
哇 全部都内行人
够狠
三四十块申报转让
后来得到二十块
哇 赚翻了他们
他们赚翻了
看利多去买的人赔惨了
对 所以小哥应该这时候
也给他来个混鼠摸鱼
放空一下
有有有
有空到
小哥你都有参与耶
无意不予耶
当然啦 研究这个就是为了赚钱嘛
所以金彩科有空蠻多的
但是刚刚我们看了很多主力没有错
他要怎么样跟我们均线扣底做配合呢
做配合我们之后会提到
好
我们再来看一下
来
这个是主力买超月线上升
均线来了
月线上升
来
主力买超
老师又要来考了
好
是学生聆听教诲
对
好
请问
是
这档股票
在沿途中其实你都可以买
对
都可以买
因為月線上升嘛
月線上升 主力買都可以買
到這邊突破也很漂亮
你猜猜
未來股價怎麼樣
好 我先問喔
請問老師 小哥老師
你是買在這裡嗎
這檔至少沒有猜
因為它比較扭啦
我比較喜歡活潑一點的
本來想說看老師在哪裡
我就見人說人話
巨大捷安特的公司耶
好公司啊
主力是一直買一直買
主力一直買 沒錯
然后线也一直往上弯
没有下弯的状态
对啊
要我的话
目前看来没有什么别的风险
目前看起来
老师我语代保留
没错
你这样很好
你在这边买其实也不错
对
你只要设好停损点
设好停损点
为什么呢
看起来万里无云
我们这样讲
这个主力买月线上升
股价上涨
月线已经给主力交代了
我都涨了
你买我都涨了
就是这一片已经赚钱了
主力买让股价推上去了
未来怎么样
除非主力继续买
假如主力改成卖超的话
后面可能会跌
所以我们还是要看主力的动向
看它之后的动向
所以你买一张股票
你都要设好你的停顺点
设好停顺点
即便主力之前是买
不代表主力未来是会买的
那老师
那我停损点怎么设
跌3%也是停损
跌5%也是停损
现在看起来都好端端
我要设多少
你可以
我是觉得你可以设个5%
因为盘中要跌到5%
但今天就有点问题了
所以小哥的容忍度
其实是蛮低的
做短线容忍度要低一点
5%就要停损掉
就是高点
就是你看到高点跌5%
我现在进场就要注意了
因为其实说实话
已经涨一段了
長一段了 主力也買一段了
沒錯 主力買一段長一段
要小心喔 我們來看
接下來怎麼樣 之後
給各位看一下 公布答案
之後主力轉成賣超
主力跑了 股價就跌下來了
但是我上完你的課我就知道
主力轉賣的時候我也要跑了
對 沒錯
來看一下這一檔
主力大買股票盤整
跟剛剛不是差不多嗎
不大一樣喔
這是股價在這邊混喔
可是主力一路買
股價在混
主力吸貨
這是傳統的吃貨
台達電好公司啊
你看我基本面出生
所以我就忍不住
環保概念股啊
對
台股長青樹
又盤整
主力又吸貨
快要發動了
我買
好
太漂亮了
這種是我們的最愛
我們最喜歡主力買
可是股價還沒漲
主力買股價還沒漲
最漂亮
對
因為你進去買
你跟主力在一起嘛
安全
那主力吃夠了之後
他們就會拉一波
所以吃多久呢
吃多久是個問題
那我買了我要等很久
我要買全證嗎
千萬不要
因為你買全證
不知道什麼時候發動
全證要在什麼時候買
發動那一天買
沒有發動不能買
那我就當存股
我就當存股
台南店好公司
我們來看未來發生什麼事情
這裡
這一段啊 主力吃嘛
吃一吃肉
吃飽後股價就漲了
小哥下一堂課可以教我們
主力什麼時候吃飽嗎
主力什麼時候吃飽
很簡單
我們講這個布林軌道
布林軌道
布林軌道的上軌翹起來就可以了
好 那我們下一集來講布林軌道我們來講那個上軌的怎麼看它翹起來好 或是小哥你上車的时候通知我我就买在跟主力在一起了好我们赖群组再聊一下好来接下来给你看一下
这比较特别一点
这个上一集我们也有讲过
对
主力大卖后股价上涨
这个有点颠覆刚刚我们学的东西
对因为这个大部分主力买股价涨
对
那主力卖股价涨
通常背后都有故事
是啊 这也太夸张
这卖很凶耶
卖得很凶
然后还涨那么高
还涨那么多
主力大卖后股价上涨
那这个涨股票就要很小心了
对 因为这一档
小哥上一集有剧透
它其实是两股势力在交错嘛
神秘社团跟主力
PTT法人
这两边对插
对作
差人讲了那个要逼的
好 对作
好
我们看一下
在这个点
在这个高点
来考照话
好
你看到高点之后
对
月线在几天后
很容易下弯
往后20天
对
股价没创新高啊
扣底值就赖到高点
对 我跟你讲
制作人都不会剪这段
他很喜欢看我被考到
高点后往后20天
往后20天
那月线就怎么样
我们看啊
你看真的
那20天後
你看這月線是不是就下彎了
對
月線下彎這檔股票
其實月線下彎不代表股票一定死
沒有
但是主力大賣
月線下彎
它非常嚴重
好
月線下彎股票不一定完蛋
不一定完蛋
可是月線下彎加上主力在大賣
主力賣超的話
那幾乎就是完蛋
因為只要月線下彎
這追上來的全部都什麼
是散戶耶
不是阻力 阻力都倒光了
散戶人手一張啊
那不得了
只要月線下彎 風吹草動了
大家都很害怕
所以你看到高點出現20天內
是讓你跑的喔
20天內你沒有跑的話
月線等著彎喔
月線一彎 散戶殺生熔熔
對 融資多殺多
不得了了
不過我看這一檔滿可憐的
散戶很多都沒跑
到現在還爆炸
對啊 可能還在那個社團裡面
有可能
有可能 對啊
所以有很多種不同的類型
所以遇到不好的狀況的時候
高點往後數20天
我們這20天內最好跑掉
不要那麼怕說賠了錢或什麼的
能跑就跑
很多人 我們要特別講一下
很多人問小哥說
要不要賣股票
他都拿什麼來問你知道嗎
拿他的對賬單來問
這個賠錢的要不要賣
沒有再問你賺錢的
賺錢的他都賣掉了
都問賠錢
對啊 都綠的就對了
都是賠錢的
都不問這張股票是什麼
小哥請問這賠錢要不要賣
什麼股票也不講
等一下下完節目我也來問一下
所以不要因為有沒有賠錢
來錢進去要不要賣
該賣就賣
你預測到月線會往下彎
主力再賣 任賠砍出
不要再留戀了啦
因為你之後你把錢拿去做別的
買別的標的對不對
還是會漲啊
來看我們的歌友籌必報
就會賺回來了
對啊 我們會幫各位找
那種主力再買的
好
好 來 這個剛剛有點劇透了
好 有點劇透了
主力大賣股價盤整
這後來會怎樣
後來會怎樣
可是因為剛剛有點劇透了嘛
它有大股東申報轉讓
假設我不知道好了
可是假設我不知道
我看到主力一直賣
其實我還是會把它賣掉
對 可是很多人
都沒看到這條線喔
我覺得他們蠻勇敢的
他們只看這K線
只看這K棒你不曉得到底要不要
對 因為它在盤整
但是你看到主力滿在超
這個該賣了
我們來看後面結局怎麼樣
應該說主力既然落跑
我們就不要賭了
我們來看一下這檔後面很慘
之前在38塊主力申報轉浪
快跌到你看 跌到快20塊
好慘
主力倒完後之後股價下跌
主力好不容易把你們這些散戶
吸引到山上去了
前四月一天一直
就讓你們在山上看著星星
他不會來救你們的
好 所以是不是小哥
主力買啊
我還是得看一下股價的位置
但是主力賣我就真的不要再囉嗦了
交底抹油呢
也不一定
也不一定啊
我們來看一下
那假如低檔主力大賣
哎呦
你真的是很懂我的心耶
因為我剛剛想說
賣我就不跟他玩了
管他低檔高檔
股價都要看高檔跟低檔
好吧
好公司巨洋
第一檔主力大賣你看在這邊
它已經躺在這裡
股價已經快跌不下去了
可是主力還在賣
這叫主力大賣賣不下去
真的喔
可是人家說低還有更低
它賣不下去很容易怎麼樣
很容易怎麼樣
很容易
我們來看很容易之後
主力假如轉買
賣不下去之後
這裡賣不下去
主力一轉買
股價就往上漲
所以我们要看两个轮回
基本上他在卖的时候
小哥应该也不建议我们去买
可是如果他已经杀到很低
主力又转买
这时候再去买就对了
因为杀到很低在那边混的时候
扣底值就到低点
只要股价一上涨
越先就容易上升了
所以这边也配合了均线是上扬的
然后主力又买
就完全回复到一个低档
反而可以去大买的状况
没错没错
这很聪明
没有我觉得这个组合
虽然只有几种
主力卖主力买
股价高档股价低档
就这样而已
可是还是要很注意很观察
可是刚刚讲的那个主力的买卖
我们不会算分点啊
不会看分点
有没有什么好用的网站啊
好用的APP要介绍给我们
网路上其实很多啦
对
我现在介绍一个筹码K线
好
筹码K线又有名了啦
对你在网路上在Google下载都有
对
它有个免费的主力买来查询
我们来看一下这边啊
这里你点主力买卖
是
然后这里有个主力
对
你就可以看到最近主力在做什麼事情
就針對這一檔股票對不對
對
例如說主力連買你就點進去
製作單位怎麼剛好挑這一檔
這一檔是你的心頭號
其實是我們跟小哥有賴群組
最近主力買了蠻多的
我們看下主力主力蠻很多
各位還可以去看看他分點是哪些分點
是哪些分點
可是分點也是一個大學問
因為我們不像小哥都認識那些分點後面的人
所以小哥要開集分點嗎
關鍵分點
我们会教各位它的概念
但那很关键的分点
电视上不能讲出来
我们不在电视上
我们在网路上
网路上更不能讲出来
因为讲出来就搬家了
你知道吗
真的吗
小哥威力太大
不能透露
我是主力
我也很不爽
你把我讲出来
所以这边就要教大家敲碗
敲碗
因为大家一定很想知道
关键分点后面的藏镜人是谁
小哥其实都知道
所以我们现在来拗小哥
真的要做一个关键分点
让我们知道
因為那個是籌碼的不傳之密
但是哥有籌必報
想必不是個會藏私的人
小哥說不下去了
講不出來
關鍵分點
有的可以講
有的真的不能講
有的很簡單
亞泥的關鍵分點叫什麼
亞泥的關鍵分點
就在亞泥旁邊
亞泥旁邊是佐水溪
沒有 開玩笑
亞泥的關鍵分點
就跟他公司有關
雅尼是谁开的
徐旭东
东嘛 所以是哪个分点
亚东证券
可是在哪个分点你要告诉我
亚东总公司
因为大老板会在总公司下班
反正回去向下下
大家不要担心我们会严刑考打
当然也要大家敲碗
小哥要把分点的分点
要懂内
小哥才要讲
所以今天希望大家学会了
一个是来看扣底
来算均线
它到底什么时候会上扬
什么时候会下弯
再搭配小哥有提供
非常容易查的
就是筹码K线
它会告诉你主力的买卖超
那记得哦
股价在高档还是低档
跟主力买卖超
也有联动的关系哦
我们全部要学会
那有任何的问题
都有欢迎你提问给我们哦
我们也会请小哥
上来帮大家回答问题
那我们今天的
歌有筹必报就到这里了
我们下次再见了
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜